in Oklahoma drawing oil from the earth
is nothing new it's the fifth largest
producer in the United States and the
oil and gas industry brings tens of
billions of dollars into the state
economy each year but lately there have
been some earth-shaking developments
this sounds like a sonic boom it feels
like the apartment is just going to
shift right off the foundation
it'll toss you and then toss back where
you were
earthquakes here used to be rare about
one a year but over the last six years
the number has shot through the roof in
2013 they were 109 quakes over 3.0
magnitude at the current rate 2014 could
see that triple you know and you grew up
here this isn't normal
they have coincided with the rise of
fracking to extract oil and gas from the
ground there were seven more earthquakes
today
I've been invited to a meeting in
Stillwater at the home of Angela spots
residents here are trying to figure out
how to counter these unsettling
developments we can't stop fall off the
wall we've been here when every picture
on this wall shook and went sideways
you're just bombarded with noise sound
dust dirt I personally feel it's very
dangerous and unfortunately it's going
to be years before the rest of the whole
country figures that out so far we
haven't had any cracks in the ceiling
but I can feel the difference in the
floor I wish people understood how much
energy is consumed to bring all that
energy up out of the ground with all the
risk how confident are you that you can
unsettle this Leviathan because if these
are the jobs right this is the economy
in Oklahoma is that your biggest
challenge here I think so I think it is
our governor's top three contributors
their energy company
hydraulic fracturing or fracking is the
process by which water chemicals and
sand are injected into rock to dislodge
pockets of oil and gas that wastewater
then has to be disposed of either by
dumping it into evaporation pits or by
Rhian ejected it into the ground it's
this reinjection process that a study
conducted by the US Geological Survey
and several American universities has
linked to the earthquakes the earthquake
increase is unprecedented in Oklahoma
Bob Rebecca's is a research hydrologist
with the USGS and co-authored that study
injection has occurred in Oklahoma for
many decades it's what may be relevant
is that injection has doubled in the
same time frame in the state so
injection rates have been increasing as
he's unconventional oil and gas that
technologies have been increasing across
the state the boom in fracking is
causing friction between the industry
and landowners I'm about to go see Earl
Hatley he's been an environmental
activist for decades and is a big
opponent of fracking and wastewater
injection that looks like a wastewater
injection well right hmm that's being
blamed for the earthquakes and how many
earthquakes have we had in this area in
recent times poke hard hundreds Earl has
been hearing from oil companies who want
to explore for oil on his land in
January I got a letter from a contractor
on behalf of Devon they had a contract
with the letter they want to come onto
my property and do a seismic survey
explore for oil and I just threw it away
if they find oil the companies may not
have to ask for permission to extract it
in Oklahoma mineral ownership is
separate from land ownership which has
tipped the balance in favor of the big
oil and gas companies so you're saying
they can do what they want really how do
you fight such a big machine in Oklahoma
that's a difficult thing you have to be
brave
have to be willing to take whatever they
throw it for more than a month I'd been
requesting interviews with the top oil
and gas companies so now I'm gonna try
to show off on the front door and see if
they'll talk to me
according to our Chesapeake Energy
completely be message hi Gordon we're
doing a piece on the wastewater
injection in Oklahoma would really
appreciate if you could find the time
thanks a lot no one answered but the
Oklahoma City police arrived soon
afterward who was you supposed to meet
with uh well I'd sent multiple requests
to Gordon Pennoyer sir
anyway guys I love that cat here now we
got a similar response from Devin the
fifth largest natural gas company in the
country so we were wondering if we could
get a line from Devin like anything on
camera she reporting so I was just a
Devon Energy Center the biggest building
in town I went to enchance my luck they
threw us out when we started researching
this story this man got in touch he
drives the trucks that carry millions of
gallons of used water from the fracking
sites to weight is disposed of unlike
the oil companies he wanted to talk but
asked us to hide his identity what am I
seeing over here this is a reservoir
where they dump their frack trucks at
farmers and landowners can just dig a
hole and charge people to unload their
frack trucks here the dirty water that
they've used them I thought the dirty
one thurgood's gets pumped underground
in the injection wells they do but this
is another way of disposing of frack
water you just come out here dig a hole
charge people to back in and lo he's
worried about more than the earthquakes
and fears that reckless dumping of
chemical laced wastewater into these
pits will contaminate the groundwater
there's not even a tarp out here this is
just ground to water the state's making
a lot of money out of this you think
they're gonna care or do anything about
it I don't think so I think that it's
good for Walmart it's good for the gas
stations it's good for everybody to have
this kind of money
coming around and I don't think
anybody's going to say anything until
the groundwater is gone and you have to
go somewhere else to get water in Norman
Oklahoma a town-hall meeting has been
organized to discuss the local impact of
fracking with support from the Sierra
Club a national environmental group
we've done our best to make sure that
everyone can not only hear but do have
also the opportunity to at least submit
their questions both supporters and
opponents of fracking showed up from
environmental activists to hardline
conservatives the room filled up early
leaving many frustrated outside I worked
for living like a lot of people don't I
work in the woman gas industry I've been
doing it for over 45 years
ah relax
okay it has to do in my wife with her
they have no idea what's cracking yet no
to keep tempers from boiling over
the audience was asked to submit their
questions in writing now all this talk
about potentially banning fracking is
this something that you see is possible
here in Norman could could Norman do
this is it considering it first of all
is I'm going to show you there's a state
statute that specifically contemplates
that charter cities at least have the
ability to both regulate and prohibit
the industry thank you
general public in specific parts the
public they over react to things they
don't understand and they and then and
what's not an overreaction if your
ground shaking underneath you know I
mean limit let's we're talking about
fracking no kinase a wastewater
injection part of the big picture
outside the forum I finally got to speak
with oil industry representatives you
guys don't believe the study has any
legs to stand on study believes that it
could be linked study does not say that
causality then correspondents are the
same thing there are corresponding
themes that have happened but surely we
don't know have you got to go okay let's
look at this well there are other
corresponding things such as the massive
major earthquakes occurring over the
world at the same time that are directly
relate to what's happening in Oklahoma
so where is the anti-fracking hysteria
coming from and they're not based on
science it's true that scientists
haven't so far established that the
injection of wastewater produced by
fracking is causing the exponential rise
in earthquakes in Oklahoma
but earthquakes are a problem the future
of the freshwater supply is a concern
that there's a correlation between
fracking and both is proven yet so
polarized other positions here and so
massive is the oil and gas industry that
even if science does establish a causal
link I'm not sure this battle will stop
at all they're gonna make as much money
as what they can all I can make it
without being regulated want more
download the aj+ mobile app and join the
conversation
available in your App Store now